what we do what McLaren is all about is
is using technology to build the best
sports cars in the world in whatever
segment we go into and we will be choosy
about what segment we're going to
because we do genuinely want to to lead
the market I think we've proven that
would be one we've now gone in as you
say to the to the segment up against
Ferrari a brilliant Lamborghini but we
go in as the most technically advanced
car in its class you quoted the
horsepower figures it's the most
powerful card as fastest the best
drivers car there so that's what we set
out to do we set out to use technology
to build the best drivers got in the
class and then you're going to go even
further down you got to start competing
with Portia's as well like that that's
something for the future does it dilute
the brand in any way I think if we stay
with our principal our principal is to
make the best cars for drivers whether
that be on the road or on the track and
we use technology to do it and if we
stay with that principle and we pick the
segments we can go into where we can we
can be as fast leader then then no it
doesn't dilute it we can't go down right
down market we can't produce cheap
sports cars with the level of technology
we have in them but I think we can bring
the car to market and they say
two-thirds of the price another 650s and
have a car that again will outperform
minute segments and that's the goal I've
got off the question because everybody's
talking about it here Stefan bickleman
over a Lamborghini wants to produce an
SUV can you ever see yourself doing that
no I can't sister but now it's always
dangerous in this life as you get older
you realize saying never is a strong
thing there is absolutely no intention
there's no discussion there's no plans
in in repairin to build actually we are
a sports car company it's all about
driving pleasure for us so I'm sure my
engineers could design one but it's
absolutely not what we want to do